first of all congratulate a Canasta this
various party it's a party
look we're turning up with you Jason
Congrats first of all this is a big
moment in your career right it is it's
awesome I cannot believe this is
happening right now I just did the hawk
on the blue carpet it was an amazing
performance your family's here the
family affair your kids they actually
have cameos in this film can you tell us
how big the cameos are yeah they were
actually sending but I think James cut
them out so first solo film you know we
actually see Aquaman and we learn more
about him what do you think fans are
gonna take away from seeing Aquaman in
the standalone film he's just a little
more relatable I don't know he's a very
flawed he's a flawed character that's
why I enjoyed playing him he's learning
at the same time it's all the people
that are around him they believe in him
more than himself so which comes down to
life I mean so people you surround
yourself and people that raise you up to
the next level so one more question
before I let you go in an interview you
recently said that you can understand
that Ben Affleck and Henry Cavill
decided to step away from Batman and
Superman because there's other
opportunities to absolutely not I don't
want to he loves the character he's not
what I'm saying no it's absolutely not
you